ya estamos listos para empezar a
conectar nuestros componentes y así
formar circuitos y una de las dos cosas
que van a ser más útiles son las leyes
de kirchhoff y bueno en este vídeo vamos
a hablar acerca de la ley de voltaje de
kirchhoff si nos fijamos en este
circuito aquí tenemos una fuente de
voltaje y digamos que es de 10 volts y
por acá tenemos un resistor conectado a
esta fuente digamos que es un resistor
con una resistencia de 200 ohms y esto
es nada más para ponerle algunos números
y para poder hablar más claramente al
respecto ahora una de las cosas que
puedo hacer aquí es ver cuánto voltaje
tiene en los distintos nodos por ejemplo
aquí tenemos un nodo y de forma
arbitraria voy a decir que aquí tenemos
goltz pero si nos vamos por aquí en el
circuito y pasamos por esta fuente de
voltaje este nodo de aquí va a tener 10
volts y vamos a utilizar un lenguaje un
poco técnico pero aquí estamos en un
nuevo con voltaje cero y al pasar por la
fuente de voltaje hay un aumento de
voltaje o también se le puede llamar
incremento de tensión porque al voltaje
también le llamamos tensión o diferencia
de potencial es entonces aquí como está
subiendo el voltaje decimos que hay un
aumento de voltaje
ok aquí hay un aumento pero ahora si
estamos en este nodo parados digamos en
este punto y pasamos del otro lado del
resistor pasamos por aquí entonces
disminuye el voltaje porque llegamos a
un voltaje cero el voltaje está bajando
de 10 volts acero volts y
esto se llama una caída de voltaje es
una caída de voltaje aunque ya veces le
llamamos caída de tensión o simplemente
caída éstos son los términos que
generalmente usamos ahora lo podemos
decir también de otra forma aquí esta
caída de voltaje podemos decir que la
caída es de 10 volts caída de 10 volts o
también refiriéndonos a esto mismo de
aquí podemos decir que el aumento es de
menos 10 volts y estos dos de aquí
quieren decir exactamente lo mismo
quieren decir que el voltaje pasó de 10
volts a 0 volts a través de este
registro de 200 oms y bueno podemos
escribir por aquí una expresión acerca
de esto que nos dice que el aumento de
voltaje menos la caída de voltaje tiene
que ser igual a cero aumentamos 10 volts
y luego disminuimos 10 volts entonces
nos quedamos con cero volts y eso es lo
que tenemos aquí ahora
esta es una de las formas de la ley de
kurtzio de voltaje
aunque la ley es más general porque nos
dice que la suma de todos los aumentos
de voltaje menos la suma de todas las
caídas de voltaje es igual a cero ahora
si queremos poner los números que
tenemos aquí el aumento de voltaje es 10
volts menos la caída de voltaje es de 10
volts y esto definitivamente es igual a
cero bueno y ahora vamos a dibujar otro
circuito pero esta vez vamos a tener dos
resistor es y cada uno con una
resistencia de 100 oms bueno ahora vamos
a poner los voltajes nuevamente esta va
a ser una fuente de voltaje de 10 volts
y en este nodo tenemos cero volts
entonces aquí en este nodo tenemos 10
volts y ahora tenemos que averiguar cuál
es el voltaje en este otro nodo pero
pues aquí tenemos 2 resistor es en serie
y además tienen exactamente la misma
resistencia entonces este nodo tiene un
voltaje
5volts aquí tenemos 5 goles y de aquí
acá también tenemos 5 volts y bueno de
aquí para acá tenemos 10 volts
pero bueno revisemos nuevamente este
circuito
digamos que empezamos desde aquí y a
partir de aquí contamos todos los
aumentos y las caídas de aquí para acá
pasando por esta fuente de voltaje
tenemos un aumento de 10 volts luego al
pasar por este resistor de aquí para acá
tenemos una caída de 5 volts y
finalmente tenemos aquí otra que ayuda
de 5 volts y llegamos nuevamente a este
nodo que tiene un voltaje de 0 volts y
así como lo hicimos en el circuito
pasado podemos sumar los aumentos de
voltaje menos las caídas de voltaje
entonces tenemos un aumento de voltaje
de 10 volts y luego una caída de 5 volts
entonces estamos 5volts otra caída de 5
goltz
y nos queda pero ahora si lo queremos
escribir en términos generales lo que
hacemos es escribir la suma de todos los
aumentos de voltaje menos la suma de
todas las caídas de voltaje y eso tiene
que ser igual a cero esta es una de las
formas de la ley de voltaje de kirchhoff
la suma de los aumentos de voltaje menos
la suma de las caídas de voltaje siempre
es igual a cero
ahora hay una forma todavía más compacta
de escribir esta ley y ésta nos dice que
empecemos en algún punto y simplemente
sumemos todos los aumentos de voltaje
pero tomando en cuenta que si tenemos
una caída de voltaje eso es igual a un
aumento pero con signo negativo ok
entonces si empezamos en este punto aquí
tenemos un aumento de 10 volts
pero luego aquí tenemos un aumento de
menos 5 volts y aquí tenemos otro
aumento de menos 5 volts y entonces nos
queda de todas formas 10 menos 5 menos 5
que también es igual a cero pero
entonces podemos escribir por aquí que
la suma del cambio de voltaje ya sea que
siempre veamos el aumento o la caída
pero la suma de los cambios de voltaje a
lo largo de todo el lazo es igual a cero
ok tenemos aquí este lazo y si sumamos
todos los cambios de voltaje con el
signo adecuado nos tiene que dar igual a
cero ok esta es la ley de voltaje de
kurtzio ahora nosotros empezamos desde
este punto pero en realidad
pudimos haber empezado desde cualquier
punto del circuito por ejemplo si
hubiéramos empezado por aquí entonces
tendríamos primero un cambio de voltaje
de menos 5 volts después otro cambio de
voltaje de menos 5 volts
y finalmente un cambio de voltaje de 10
volts y la suma de todas estas menos 5
510 nos sigue dando igual a 0 ahora de
la misma forma también podemos empezar
por aquí pero o ir en sentido contrario
también se puede y entonces lo que
tenemos es un aumento de 5 volts luego
otro aumento de 5 volts y finalmente una
caída de voltaje de 10 volts así es que
esto funciona no importa en donde
empieces ni en qué dirección lo hagas
pero hagamos una última observación a
final de cuentas estos cambios de
voltaje son los voltajes de los
componentes de nuestro circuito nada más
que tenemos que poner mucha atención si
es un cambio positivo o negativo
ok esa es la esencia de la ley de
voltaje de kirchhoff y vamos a
utilizarla junto con la ley de corriente
de kerchove y éstas van a ser nuestras
herramientas para hacer análisis de
circuitos